There is a time in every person's life
when drinking water is deadly.
Even as much as a few
ounces is enough to kill.
The average healthy adult is
made up of 55 to 60% water.
The average baby, on the other
hand, is roughly 75% water.
And that difference is why
babies shouldn't drink water
before they're at least six months old.
Not from the tap or a well or a spring.
Plain water is just plain off limits.
You see, everyone's kidneys have a limit
to how much water they can handle.
Break that limit, and the excess water
will back up into your bloodstream,
where it dilutes the salt,
or sodium, in your blood.
Once your blood dips below 0.4
ounces of sodium per gallon,
you're at risk of a condition
called Hyponatremia.
It happens when your cells
try to return sodium levels
to normal by absorbing the extra water
and swell up like a water
balloon in the process,
causing complications like confusion,
vomiting and muscle spasms.
Hyponatremia is common in marathon runners
who drink too much too fast during a race
without also providing enough sodium
to balance out their blood.
And if you keep drinking,
that excess water
will eventually reach
the cells in your brain.
By this point, you have a dangerous case
of water intoxication, which affects
roughly 200,000 Americans each year.
It occurs when your brain cells swell,
which builds up pressure inside your skull
that can lead to seizures, brain damage,
and, in sever cases, death.
But don't worry, dying from
water intoxication
is extremely hard for
a fully-grown human.
An adult would have to
drink 2.5 to 5 gallons
every few hours to reach that point.
But for newborns, it's a different story.
Their kidneys are about
half the size of an adult's,
so they can't hold much
water to begin with.
And it takes just a few
ounces to cause problems.
On top of that, their kidneys
aren't developed enough yet
to properly filter water, so any water
that enters their body ends
up in the circulatory system,
where it dilutes their blood
and increases their
water content by 7 to 8%.
But it's not just drinking straight H2O
that poses a threat.
In fact, most cases of water
intoxication in infants
don't even involve a glass of water.
A common mistake is when
people dilute baby formula
too much by accident, or when parents
dunk their infants up and
down in a swimming pool,
and in the process the infant
gulps in too much water.
It's important that if your baby
is showing signs of water intoxication
that you take them to
the hospital immediately,
where a doctor will likely
provide some form of fluids
like intravenous saline solution
to bring the infant's
sodium levels up to normal.